counselors and whomever else is here I'd
like your attention for dr. Roy Lodge MB
who will say prayers
I've got my mic on can I be assured that
everyone to the rear of the council
chamber can hear fine first item on the
agenda is apologies for absence can we
have the readout please
Thank You chairman we've received
apologist and councillors Bromwich
Charles gets us Kendall Perry and
Richards chair yes I've got a couple of
comments on the minutes if I may
are they relevant to the minute well
yeah well they're they're about the
minute so they're very relevant to them
three points firstly when it came to the
question that I was prevented from our
seeing last time the minutes tone
reflect the fact that I was could he
prove nted from asking I know in
subsequent emails traffic the decision
that was given to you it was claimed
because the wording wasn't agreed with
respect the wording was agreed by me
I gather there was some other subsets
point of order which allows if there's a
use of bad language or if an individual
is attacked for the question to be
stopped but I would like the minutes to
reflect the fact I was prevented from
asking that question
it's a mute point in many respects
because residents have come along today
to our similar questions so we'll get
the point across but I would ask that
the first point secondly my oral
question on neighborhood plans I had
some detailed questions I noted the time
I would expect the leader to have all
the answers at his fingertips but the
following day I did write to Dave where
I'm a leader spelling out what those
questions were and I was expecting in
the minutes to have detailed answers
there so it's one point of clarity
should we as members be expecting our
questions to be asked if not at the
meeting at least in detail afterwards so
I was disappointed by that and thirdly
on the EU motion leader the reality is
it claims there was a vote on a
substantive motion there kitty wasn't
last time my understanding
that you have been are subsequently to
rule on whether it mattered that there
was no vote on that substantive motion
and I am told your you are all-powerful
as we all know because like I said but I
am slightly surprised where that
precedent takes us to so it almost seems
to me that we could not have a vote on
anything and you could determine because
we're unable to challenge you apparently
about that boat so I would just like
clarification as to whether you were
asked and that was your comment but if
so I think my minutes need to reflect
the fact there was no vote on the
substantive motion and it was your
ruling that actually voted that the
substantive motion was passed thank you
there's quite a long catalogue there I
would suggest that we take on board and
come back to you on a separate occasion
because ask for time frame on that I
think cancer you've had enough we've got
your sense of what you're on about and
we will deal with it subsequently other
comments on the minutes no so we can
take them
then to ask disclosures of interest
anyone got any disclosures of interest
no that's fine excellent thank you now
we have got a number of announcement and
the particular one is for those who have
had 40 years service with our authority
since 1970 1977 matters and we've got
certificates to present to them which
are we're happy to do from the floor
look life on it
unless I've alluded to 40 years is a
long time to serve one organization but
I do believe that in any organization
one wants a sense of history so sorry
chair but I'm happy to read the
ninety-eight do you wanna sit you wanna
say for you well thank you
you need a sense of history but you also
need adapting to changing circumstances
because there's nothing more constant
than change and in reflecting over the
last 40 years one can measure the
difference between the management of a
local authority then and now and our
staff who have served us within that
period of time thank you very much
indeed
for what you have given us my term of
service isn't quite as long as that from
about 15 years short but you've done
extremely well and I'm more than
delighted to pass the long service award
certificates to you and I think council
web is going to read the sorry I beg
your pardon
Thank You chairman just to clarify it's
not quite 40 years we have got a number
of staff here who have worked for the
cancer for an awful long time I don't
think any bone analyst has done 40 years
but having said that it's in excess of
25 years so I'm really pleased to be
able to to read these names and
recognize stuff for the long service of
the council and the first of those names
is Tina brain who has done 31 years with
the council
[Applause]
yes so just to confirm the team that is
a PA to the executive directors okay the
opportunity to get back the next name's
Chris Dobson Chris Stubbs and
environmental maintenance officer and
he's done 27 years okay next on the list
is Paul Harris planning policy officer
who's worked for the counts for 29 years
[Applause]
okay the next on the list Tony Horton
Senior Planner 26 years okay next up
it's Caroline Laver lunch artists
assistant 26 years
[Applause]
and the next person is Jason Lorenz
business development money toast in 25
years and next we have Jackie Morris
Support Officer Planning admin Houston
32 years
[Applause]
and the next person up is Renata must
district housing enable our 28 years
[Applause]
and we've now got somebody who's getting
towards 40 years but not not quite there
yet soon a she assistant police officer
34 years
[Applause]
I know somebody at the other end of the
room Caroline mesh senior Democratics
officer 25 years
[Applause]
and now we have refresh forestry and
landscape officer 27 years
[Applause]
and remember staff who's got the equal
highest number of years no Shadbolt
corporate fraud office for 34 years and
[Applause]
we now have Tammy Swan Senior Planner 25
years
[Applause]
chairman last but not least we can't
have him in his own one so Dave Webb he
says he executive director 28 years
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right other announcements prior to the
meeting I received a petition about a
planning application at Southam who is
15 if we go to oh four seven and outline
application which will be presented to
the monitoring officer that will be done
by mrs. Flavell would you like first of
all to just say a few words to the
council mrs. flavor
we just have some questions the first
one is why was this application not
adjourned
and considered a tan meet another
meeting
clearly the counselors were given
incorrect and insufficient information
to enable them to vote and looking at
your response if you look at the revised
application part you've got a date of a
25th of February 2016 and below on other
matters
you've got the date as the 25th of
February 2015 which doesn't give much
faith in what's actually going ahead
thank you mrs. Fabian I wish to present
the petition to the monitoring officer
please I would like to present this
petition to revoke the application on
behalf of myself and residents and
response I don't know whether you can
actually give thank you right members
are now asked the vice chairman to
report on his visit to China he will
give a short presentation covering the
important issues
Thank You mr. chairman as you may know
the Chairman leader who invite you to
through sroi as guests of the foo show
districts mayor and general secretary I
attended on behalf of the Chairman six
days three days traveling and three days
of meetings and conferences firstly I'd
like to express our thanks to the mayor
and leaders of foucha providing
Stratford to be part of and to share
their vision for the future but why is
China interested in Stratford and
Shakespeare that interest springs from
the top tiers of government in 2015 the
president of China spoke with the
Chinese / poet Tang Shan Xue relatively
unknown outside China of the Shakespeare
of the East in 2016 their Minister of
Culture organized an exhibition
comparing the life and times of
Shakespeare and Tang Shan Xue and that
December Xinhua the official Chinese
news agency released an animated music
video when sheep Shakespeare meets Tang
Shan Xue China and full surely the home
of tank Shan Xue is taking its literary
connections with Stratford and
Shakespeare very seriously following the
president's comments strap was invited
to it to celebrate the joint 400th
anniversary of the parents deaths with a
civic visit to foosh oi followed by
return visits for the leaders to
Boucherie
australoid to stratford for
Shakespeare's birthday celebrations what
we learnt on this trip was through a
system of three to four million people
as a modern and rapidly expanding city
and it has plans for further significant
growth and ambitions to elevate tangs
international profile to match that of
Shakespeare and fufun for foolish order
City global recognition alongside
Stratford in the city planning Hall a
planning office somewhat larger than we
used to sing in Stratford we saw an
exhibition of the city's plans for the
next 15 years 2030 a
Amyx shift from the old to the new those
little town plans on city maps in
reverse order moving on this photograph
is of a 3d model of the old town the
original historic city the middle of the
future is some is rather more
substantial you can see from the scale
of the people with people standing on
the far side of the room it is
breathtaking and very detailed whilst
the city's plans for expansion of bold
its ambitions for the Performing Arts
are remarkable the conference were
invited to attend included speakers from
the performing arts from Russia America
Hungary Italy Albania Spain as well as
the UK starting our district councillor
leader Crescenta and from the
Shakespeare Institute in Stratford part
of Birmingham University professor
Tiffany Stern delegate to the conference
attended from many other countries not
previously mentioned as well as locally
from the birthplace trust and the
Stratford Herald the presence of such an
international advisor scroop
demonstrates Fischer is clear ambitions
to be involved in the Performing Arts on
a global scale crucial his plans include
the building of full-sized reproduction
of Stratford at the time of Shakespeare
on a 89 hectare site just under half the
size of long master at sound Wang just
outside for sure
construction is already underway and we
understand is planned to be completed in
2018 19 the development will include a
theater along with a 5-star tourist
accommodation the road infrastructure
some marriage concerns as here is
already in place the building of a new
international airport is to start next
year for sure it already has a 1,300
seat theater in which we saw a
production
Tang's Andrews most famous work the P&A
of pavilion the city will therefore have
at least two large theatres in addition
the city has already begun the
restoration of Tanks Andrews own home
and the surrounding villages of village
other which includes a further smaller
theater and the development of a Museum
and exhibition center dedicated to tank
sanzu the similarities with Stratford
are striking what the visit demonstrated
to Stratford delegation is that through
showing is already investing millions on
its city and its infrastructure and now
is looking to realize its global
cultural ambitions those ambitions might
bring a new interpretation Shakespeare's
words if all the worlds of stage to be
fair a para price but paraphrased all
the world to be its stage Stratford has
a unique opportunity through the linking
of Shakespeare with tank chang-su the
potential silat synergies in the arts
education tourism and culture between a
few short and Stratford although nearly
on opposite sides of the globe can be
developed for the benefit of both
through shy and Stratford if we accept
their invitation we could do nothing all
through a lack of very robust and
coordinated response from all those who
needed to be involved fail but I feel we
would regret it is trapped food was to
be left behind at the stage door
alternatively as this council the
corresponding body chosen by the
district of foucha is already in a
strong position I believe District
Council should not only continue to be
involved with Stratford's response but
should take a leading role in that
response to ensure Stratford the
district and its residents maximise the
benefit of this opportunity
having seen the energy enthusiasm and
funding through show has for this unique
project I believe that strap through
through all its constituent parts the
RSC the birthplace trust the Shakespeare
Institute cares
as well as its residence through this
council can only benefit from being
involved in developing this unique
global project Thank You mr. shell Thank
You Council it certainly brings out some
very fundamental points
we as an area to acknowledge and I
appreciate what you have introduced us
to now the next item I now invite the
leader of the council and the head of
paid service to give their announcements
chairman I don't have any formal
announcements chairman plus one
announcement from me the leader has
informed me that councilor brahmic she's
no longer a member of the conservative
group as a result of that the political
balance has been recalculated and
everybody should have a copy with the
papers chairman are we looking for
agreement on the calculation of the
figures normally these figures are given
out in advance so that groups can agree
the allocation of seats across
committees the announcement today is the
first that we heard of this whilst it's
the first we would certainly appreciate
agreement to the recalculation bearing
in mind that the figures are not wholly
sort of out of water compared with the
totality of the elected members
germán the net effect to answer
counselor Morse's query of the
recalculation is to remove one committee
seat on LSC from the conservative party
and reallocate that to the new band of
to independence that is the allocations
to the Liberal Democrats and labor are
completely unchanged although I didn't
have a hand in this calculation as it
was a routine operational matter I left
it to the officers the way I intended to
play that is to remove councilor
Bromwich from the conservative
representation on the OSC because we
have one seat less and then presumably
there might be an opportunity for him to
get it back but that's not a question
for me to decide whichever on that basis
I'm happy to accept the paper thing fine
I thought you may be particularly as a
particular party is the one which has
been to serve and just can't remember
the name but I'm sure you can recall
we've got three remaining actually
because of the presentation on the very
first one and I now invite mrs. Victoria
Olcott to present her question
thank you everybody
in respect of the 500 home development
of Bishops in Lane Planning Committee
West granted Commission which included
land set aside for educational purposes
can you confirm this is still the case
you see I produced a a reply for you
this also came up at the recent steering
group meeting and I'm happy to include
you in the further response I give to
Frank's as well on that if that would
help help you in that regard thank you
thank you can I ask the supplementary
question one supplementary certainly
thank you well explicitly told
repeatedly join these steering group
meetings that this land would be for
educational purpose and now finding out
we were misled and out like planning
conditions can be changed with no
consultation and assuming that the
conditions are not met and the land
reverts back to the developers can you
commit that another section 106
application will be submitted and the
land will not prefer to housing but be
used for the community thank you very
much I'm gonna need to take some advice
from my planning officer and legal
colleagues I will do that and then I'll
come back to you with a with a with a
proper response on that and I'll aim to
try and get that to you closer play
Friday Friday's a consultation with the
developers at held at the Town Hall if
you could do it sooner than that
I would appreciate be able to go back to
my residence with them okay well I'll
pick that up with offices after the
conclusion of this meeting and see if we
can hit that for you thank you very much
the next question is actually from
Christine Strang would would you like to
come forward
at the meeting of the planning committee
West when outlying planning permission
was granted the Bishop Development
everybody was concerned about traffic in
the canal bridge so naturally assumed
there would be a core element of the
steering committees remit so why did the
council restrict the scope to exclude
these keyed elements and manipulate the
interpretation of appropriately managing
the flow of local and through traffic
from the portfolio holder thank you very
much I've set out the response they're
happy to take a supplementary question
if that helps you at all firstly can I
say on the response there was no
agreement to the terms of reference for
this steering group how can the
residents group realistically
participate in steering committee and
hold all participants accountable when
it has already been determined that none
of the contentious topics are up for
discussion and they are repeatedly told
that all the major decisions were agreed
as part of an online planning permission
we actually believed that the steering
group was set up to pay lip-service has
been a total waste of time
and has delivered no tangible benefits
thank you thank you first of all I'm
sorry that the the residence group feel
that the steering group process has
merely paid lip service and as made no
made no difference the the introduction
of steering groups is it's a relatively
new development for this Authority it
takes us into a sort of beyond what
we're required to do in terms of post
application decision engagement and with
a number of these steering groups up and
running at the moment as we as
as was set out right at the very
beginning the to give life to these
steering groups it has to follow on from
the decision of a planning committee and
the planning committee resolved to
grants outline planning permission on
that site where all of the matters then
access and were held over for a detailed
application and so the reality is that
the steering group can only deal with
the matters as far as the site was
concerned and whilst I recognize the
question and the challenges around the
traffic and the canal bridge they were
always going to be outside of our remit
to do anything about and as far as the
steering group process is concerned I
would I would not share your view that
it has not brought any benefits there
there is a design code that is being
developed and we were all at a meeting a
week or so ago and that that design code
which will hold the developer to account
around the detail of that development
has evolved and they have and the
developer has been moved and I would say
that you as a residence group you'll
represent you're one of the
representative the resident have had a
positive impact on that process
I that there are things outside of in
relation to the plan application itself
where and naboo your residence would
probably wish that that development
wasn't going ahead but we are where we
are and you have had a positive
influence and I would I would strongly
argue that the steering group process is
beneficial in that it does create a
better level of engagement around the
detail of applications once you know
committees have made their decisions
it's not then solely an officer and ward
member and develop a discussion there's
a wider those wider things I think you
have had any impact there but I know
that you won't you know your your
residence may take a different view
well thank you members of the public
that actually concludes that section
sorry oh yes of course below I beg your
pardon mr. Rowland sorry about that mr.
Romans we okay we understand from the
canals and River trust that prior to
Planning Commission being granted for
the debunked Columbia shipping lane they
were in discussion with both highway
authority and the developers regarding
setting aside funds to ensure the canal
bridge would be upgraded or rebuilt as a
two-way bridge we understand the
developer broke off discussions before a
commercial agreement could be reached
Stratford District Council then
scheduled the consideration of this
application by Planning Committee West
before CRT could respond following the
action by the developers why was this
matter considered before if the major
statutory consult he had time to respond
thank you once again I've set out a
response there and I'm happy to take a
supplementary question if you've got one
I have a response so this is new
information throughout the process
when questioned it's been stated the CRT
had gone AWOL to use the phrase these
wait words were used by planning
committee members they were used by
Warren County Council highways
representatives and no reference was
made to this document I've also spoken
to the head of estates at CRT today
they're unaware of such a letter and so
we'd like to see a copy of that letter
posted on the planning website as a
matter of significant input if this
information had been available when the
outline planning push sorry I've skipped
this page and I've also found from CRT
of the bridges in a poor state of repair
with a limited lifespan they'd be
willing to hand this over to the owners
ownership of the bridge to the
developers for free this would allow the
developers to rebuild the bridge and
remove one of the major issues
concerning local residents if this
information been available when the
outline Planning Commission been
considered would the outcome have been
different and is the council William to
make this a condition of the reserved
matters application and thereby remove a
major topic of concern for residents and
work she County Council highways I think
in relation to the point around the
correspondence and if there's
correspondence and it's in the public
domain I see no reason why unless
there's anything confidential in there
but on the assumption that it's a
response to consultation then I see no
reason why it should be published I'll
take that up with officers as to your
substantive point you know again that
that is new information and it it's very
weak when we're giving you a formal
answer to to a question I I know the
phrase about about the canals and rivers
Trust going a while was mentioned but
that Cleveland ups infiniment we're
going to put in a formal response there
we're sticking to absolutely what we can
what where we're at with the facts I
will take some further advice and from
officers around the other issue that
you've made there but I mean that's
to us I'm in terms of the canals and
rivers trusts view of the future of the
bridge from residents now I think mr.
abridge couldn't come
hence mrs. flavor did substitute for him
and that was agreed with the
representation which came with her all
happy with that so members can note that
if necessary for your contributions and
questions and the next item is the state
of the district and I call upon
councillor st. as leader of the council
to introduce this item chairman we've
had a stage of the district debate in
the council chamber every year since
2001 when the opportunity arose it is a
voluntary affair and in fact my
predecessors leader Bob Stevens did he
effectively opted out of the
government's permissions that to hold
this I say that because I've been
slightly disappointed in recent years
but the debate in that one side of the
room has used it to have a go at the
other
so effectively hopefully we could
perhaps take a lot of the very positive
stories in this year's report and look
forward with the outcomes of the
strategic review group which we take
later they're actually trying to govern
how our district is shaped and formed we
start from a good position there are 17
pages and no doubt are those that have
had the inclination will have read all
of them and there's a lot of statistics
in there unsurprisingly this report was
compiled by Simon per field as we know
his mr. statistics but he does have a
very good record of finding the right
information
and describe where we are warts and all
and if you look at the report the the
reports statistics that we get sometimes
come from the Office of National
Statistics right sometimes they come
from local service we've done a huge
resident survey this year which gave us
a very positive results and we have used
in this report some of the work that
been done by the strategic review group
governing ways of working ways of saving
money ways of actually developing the
district and it's mostly important
we've also referred to the fact that we
have a new council structure that's been
in place now for 18 months and indeed I
hope members will agree with me that
that new council structure has had a
positive benefit and this was reflected
in our Peru review report that we had
six months ago also on top of all that
we have had throughout the district a
wide range of neighborhood plans we're
actually almost getting to the stage now
where instead of saying well done
communities for producing a neighborhood
plan we started to get challenges to the
planners for the way that those
neighborhood plans are implemented and
long may that be a healthy way forward
in order for neighborhoods to govern
what their own communities will look
like it's really easy for us as a
district to say fair enough Stratford's
plotted along it's a nice country yeah
last country area let's keep development
down what we know we won't be allowed to
do that and then we'll actually sort of
keep it looking like it was that would
be a recipe for deterioration if we're
going to have a thriving district into
the future it has got to grow he's got
to grow
please that close down go away take
their employment off the streets of
Stratford I've got to be replaced by new
ones that come in and we have actually
to work with many agencies that can help
us achieve that and that is vitally
important equally well we are expected
by the government to actually turn
around and say fine you develop new
housing but we also want you to make
certain that the economics of your
district does effectively thrive and
prosper and that's a responsibility that
the increasingly comes on to district
councils other bodies might claim they
can have that responsibility but they
are not in touch with the local people
like members of this council are in
touch with our local residents and it is
vitally important that we grasp for that
so hopefully we can use the upbeat
statistics in this year's report and
have a debate now that actually it looks
forward to how we can make this district
thrive more succeed more and become a
place that we can all be proud of
Thank You chairman I know we have
questions the first was councillor Morse
German it's not a question I believe
this is a debate is it not thank you and
thank you the council the st. for this
lengthy report and to those officers
who's obviously spent a lot of time
working on it
perhaps I can pick up a couple of points
that I think perhaps councillor st. has
overlooked but in the spirit of what he
his comments I will try to make positive
suggestions for the future as to how
things can be improved chairman now he
will recall that after some prompting he
agreed to come up with a list of
shovel-ready schemes so the council can
make bids for money as and when it
becomes available
I'm afraid the report in front of us is
out of date as far as that is concerned
only one bid from the list so far and
that was for money
for a regeneration project in studly
200,000 parents on the Left reported by
councillor st. on page 27 as a notable
achievement the most notable thing so
far is that we've had to give the money
back it was two years after the grant
was made before the left withdrew and
fortunately the report makes no mention
of what this council intends to do to
make sure it doesn't happen again
shaukat sort of thing will wish to
address that the report makes several
mentions of broadband
I'm afraid it comes out in the report as
one of the areas where things seem to
have got worse
residents satisfaction with connectivity
is 3% down from 2014 despite the large
sums this council has put towards
improvements now I know councillor
kettle is very keen on broadband so I'm
sure he'll wish to comment on that item
chairman our homelessness and lack of
affordable housing things are moving
forward but very very slowly and winter
is coming to coin a phrase chairman the
clock is ticking so I think it would be
helpful to have reassurance from
councillor st. that we are fully
prepared to handle what appears to be an
increasing homelessness problem after
all we have the money not just the 1
million pounds windfall from orbit but
revenue reserves are a very high level
expected to be over 8 million pounds at
the end of the year according to the
latest forecast and of course if we were
accepted on the government's pilot
scheme on business rates as proposed by
councillor st. this morning that should
give us a further extra million pounds a
year that hasn't been forecast I know
that we need reserves to finance the
strategic review but revenue reserves
are reaching such a level though I think
it's quite reasonable to ask council a
saint for an assurance that there's
coming year at least he intends to carry
out the promises he made at the last
district elections to keep the council
tax unchanged one other point I'd like
to pick up on chairman is page 28 the
council's second objective promote
health and well-being including playing
an active role in the world
your health and well-being board now we
know under the NHS sustainability and
transformation plan it's looking at hubs
the delivery of many eight NHS services
the geographic maps of South
Warwickshire have now been published I
actually have a copy of it here chairman
I find them alarming if these are the
areas that have we served by the hubs
they are enormous one stretches from the
m42 down to a Biddeford another from
north of Wells borne down to Long
Compton the distance is to be traveled
by residents with in many cases be
impractical I'm also concerned chairman
that the County Council are looking at
hubs to provide for example services to
replace children centers is this council
crossing for the NHS hubs and the county
council hubs to be located together
there's a lot of crossover services but
I see no mention of that in the report
chairman finally the elephant in the
room brexit and its impact on the
district no mention in the report or in
the strategic review papers now I'm not
asking the cabinet to tell us what the
impact will be after all when the
Conservative government hasn't got the
faintest clue about what it would like
to see happen that would be too much
however whatever deal we get or indeed
if we don't get a deal at all the three
main industries in our area will be
significantly impacted we have jlr and a
steam arch in the district our biggest
ratepayers tourism may actually benefit
because of the claps in value was
sterling but we're already learning that
many of our tourist business businesses
are suffering from staff shortages and
without stuff they won't be able to take
advantage of extra tourists and farming
another making major local industry
faces all sorts of challenges from
brexit including loss of grants and
possible difficulties in export markets
so chairman finally what is this council
doing to help these industries have
their voices heard what are we doing to
help look at
we soften the blow for many residents
who will be affected nothing as far as I
can see now chairman we often hear
councillor st. tell us how he's had the
ear of this minister or that Minister so
we have the opportunity to pass concerns
on we could at least start by asking our
local businesses what problems they
foresee from brexit and whether they
think there is anything this council can
do to help brexit will be a major
challenge locally and we have a
responsibility to do all we can to help
residents and businesses Thank You chair
you wish to respond councillor same kind
of right new to the Vortech was next
I think counselor same kind of likely to
mention all the good bits in the report
there are some some good parts in the
report but I wouldn't be doing my job as
an opposition counselor if I just
mention those things so the one of the
most important things in the report was
how hard fuel poverty is for local
residents in the district in fact we're
in the top 40 for all local authorities
perhaps this authority who can look for
solutions perhaps creating a a company
or partnership with other authorities
actually supplying fuel and actually
giving a a better rate to our residents
than then commercial companies and other
authorities do do this and that
hopefully will bring the figure down
from 13% to below the average of 12% in
workshare again meeting house prices are
preventing people getting on the housing
ladder with earnings to price ratio is
now nine point one six twenty years ago
result it was just over half our with
council policy council policy in this
area is critical and I know some steps
are being taken regarding housing
working group which I commend but more
ideas and more work needs to be done
I believe struck that unique outcome the
economy also has challenges of house
prices somewhere paid employment but
also has the largest proportion of
working population in low-paid sectors
perhaps Stratford district council
should be developing policies to
encourage employers to pay a living wage
in these sectors life expectancy in the
poorest areas of the district also needs
to be tackled and looked at nearly five
years in three years for women and men
the difference but
the least deprived areas and the most
the areas where their wealthiest I also
picked up the numbers of people killed
on our roads as that's increased
considerably and that that needs to be
tackled and we need to be working much
more closely with the county council to
see what can be done and what funding
can come through to prevent these
terrible accidents the district has many
challenges facing it and needs more
radical policies and solutions the
document does present some but I think
it can do a lot more work to to improve
the lot on some of the points I've made
today okay next is councillor Richie
Thank You chair I'd only actually got
one comment on the entire paper but I've
developed a couple more whilst listening
to councillor fully check and cancel
remorse so perhaps I should've wait a
little while is that my hand up at the
end the first word I think might be a
typo
page 18 paragraph 4 it talks about the
number of children that are living in
poverty in Stratford district making a
comparison to 2010 it suggests that the
the measurement is 2013 I'm not sure
that doesn't seem recently enough for me
as a measurement having aware the Simons
put the wrong number on there or the
wrong year I would imagine it's the case
with one of the other but it would be
good to clarify that the other bits and
pieces that I picked up on in terms of
steadily council more so I do actually
believe that it is an accomplishment
because we did put together a cogent
plan it was a shovel-ready scheme it
generated interest from the left and
local members and as a result the money
was awarded I think as you know I've
I've had a hand in how that's progressed
I think that the goalposts have changed
I think the council has established a
position as far as to steadily site is
concerned and suddenly on the whole
actually we're talking specifically
about this site I think the portfolio
holder the council and the cabinet have
all established a position on the site
should go forward I think it's a ball
that started rolling now and I don't see
that stopping I don't see us putting our
hands up and walking away from it at all
while the let may have done so at this
particular stage I don't think any of us
are ready to do that so I think we just
continue as per usual with good
intentions for that site and we find a
way to make it happen and I genuinely
believe that we will I think that balls
are now very long I hope that gives you
some confidence and in terms of business
as you know that is my my portfolio I
think we are already working I think we
are putting effort in to support the
businesses as you rightly say tourism is
up in Stratford district an interested
in common
was made to me at her business forum was
the coming to the United Kingdom now is
no longer a bucket list item for the
rest of the world it's now a let's do it
again and again so previously people
around the world would sort of say well
at some point I'm gonna go and see the
RSC at some point we'll go
stratford-upon-avon and some port I'm
gonna go to Parliament and what's
happening now is there go into
Parliament they're going to the RSC and
then they're making plans to do it again
the following year because we've become
more affordable that's not to make any
suggestion on my position as regards
brexit by the way and certainly the work
that the growth hub is doing in
stratford-upon-avon itself I know of one
sizable business already that has had
very very strong introductions in to
China in the Chinese market that seems
to be driving forward at a tremendous
pace so operations such as venture house
getting the growth of involved in that
and then our input on the growth of is
definitely helping business I can think
of two other projects that we've got
simmering away at the moment that are in
an echo adventure house that I firmly
believe will assist businesses getting
out of the bedroom and growing into and
we're not talking about people just
coming out the bedroom going into hot
Destin or shared office space here we're
talking about businesses that are then
making that jump from a national
business to an international business so
I think we're doing an awful lot for
business throughout Stratford district
that was it Janet thank you thank you
councillor Cargill was next thank you I
suppose it depends where you where you
sit and how you interpret reports like
this but I must admit overall I feel is
an update beat report
I do appreciate their issues as with any
any district any County any any country
so there are always issues within this
in these sort of areas and I think those
are areas which you can focus on now not
say let go of the other ones but to
focus on those
which we feel well i need significant
improvement so i pick up that particular
point I notice on page 20 oh and our
schools here are performing extremely
well and exceeding the average and for
that it's down to the hard work of the
leaders and the staff in schools for
that they really applaud them and I
think we've done tremendously well in
that respect however I do have concerns
that we shouldn't lose focus on the
continuing education of these people
coming through the schooling system for
the moment and the next generation shall
we say coming through I want to be a
intern able or to have them unable to
getting more skills the ones we'll need
in the future
we've been talking about our industry
and such well we have where the
government is actually throwing its
weight behind apprenticeships no I'm
Alexa Prentiss and this I think it's a
fantastic way to get a career and to go
on and and and have a great life in the
world based on my career and my
apprenticeship now I realize that a few
administrations ago it was completely
opposite and ideological policy that
everyone had to go to university and I
know we're swishing it's switching
accross mount of apprenticeship based
solutions considering that this is a
rural area largely rural area we do have
a large number of engineering companies
something personally I wish to see
increase now part of the council
strategic vision is to contribute to a
flourishing global economy for that we
need skilled workers my question is
really always our district doing enough
to support the Prentice ships for the
next generation of our engineers that we
so desperately need
thank you Thank You mr. Sharon
councilman well my neighbor in his
response in relation to a broadband and
I would completely agree with him that
broadband is a fundamental utility
for residents and businesses of this
district what counsel Morris will be
also fully aware of is that not only on
the chairmanship of the former chair
councilor Pemberton but also on the
council house we ever had the focus for
the delivery of broadband firmly in our
sights in the RFC
it is disappointing that broadband
rollout in our district is is less than
it is in any city areas but I think it
is that demonstrates that we must all in
this council work together to ensure
that the delivery of that which is
completely outside our hands other than
they asked us for money it's outside of
our hands business run by BT UK and it
is on this council and our neighboring
district councils out of thought to push
those authorities to ensure that we do
get a robust delivery across this
district and I think that's what we're
doing in this just district we are
working very hard to identify where we
are in the pecking order and to ensure
the questions we may ask are appropriate
and get the answers back from those
deliveries to ensure they're doing their
job on a more general thing but I wasn't
expecting to ask mr. ance mr. Moss his
question is what comes out of this is
people like living here but housing is
very very expensive and if those you
have heard me in planning committees
housing in the wrong place as far as I'm
concerned is something which we need to
challenge very carefully but I think
what the numbers produced as a whole is
despite my concerns about where housing
goes we do need to have new housing in
this district not only to reduce the
average price to enable young people to
come into the district but also to
ensure that families can continue to
live in that in the district they're
brought up in and to encourage young
families in the district which will help
to revitalize things going forward
so my view from that is
I think we need to continue to be very
very careful where houses go but we do
have to accept but the core structure
figures that we've got 15,000 odd will
have to be built but what we need to do
is make sure we don't over build we've
got to that stage now we know what our
numbers are let's make sure we continue
to keep this as a rural district and
that people I note on page 21 people
liked living here because access to the
countryside that people still have a
color site to come and visit thank you
thank you chairman and I just wanted to
touch on the question of of housing and
where we are as a district and and what
we what we're looking to do everybody in
this room knows that there is an issue
around affordability for housing
everybody in this room knows there are
insufficient properties for rent and
everybody knows that there are
insufficient properties for those who
need support we rent it housing we all
accept that and we all realize that we
have to do something about that and we
have engaged in a piece of work to look
at how we can make a difference and a
number of times you know the question of
the million pounds is from you know from
the from the garage sale is raised and
guys I'm eager to spend that money but
I'm eager to spend it in the right way
at the right time to get the right
solution and I think you know we do have
to accept that what will we do have to
do some research into what is the best
solution and you counsel more sound
counsel if we check of both and continue
to both be part of the groups that are
looking at that and in very very short
order you know I mean we'll be bringing
forward some solutions for this council
to consider sir absolutely this is top
almost top front and center and is an
issue that we're going to to do
something about and we are going to be
active so I think just to have that
understanding in the meantime we
yeah we need to give some credit to our
officers because we have made
significant inroads into the numbers of
people who are in enriches reducing the
number of people who are in B&B type
accommodation the number of people who
are active actually homeless in this
district we are making progress for me
when one homeless person is in this
district is 1/2 minute I think we all in
this room share that view
but we are you know we as a collective
not just as an administration but as a
collective we are embarked on a piece of
work to actually come to a solution so I
think you know saying there's a problem
we all know there's a problem but I
think you know we you know we should
remember that we are all trying to find
a solution to that and I think we are
making significant strides towards that
and I do think that the the answers we
come up with will be radical and they
will make a significant difference and
we can all feel we can all then feel
proud to be part of that because it's
our district not anybody or anyone
parties thank you
Thank You chair just in response to the
questions on the health and well-being
board I attend the health and well-being
board as they representative of this
district the last agenda and purpose for
the agenda numbered a mere 320 the one
thing I would say about the whole health
arena at the moment is it's a very
complex and very changing environment
and I don't think there are any easy
solutions when it comes to the issue of
homes I have to say I am not clear how
they're going to work I think there is
still quite a lot of thinking to be done
by County on that and this was
reinforced when Cristina Ramos addressed
the overview and scrutiny committee last
week that even there there was a lack of
clarity about how these were going to be
configured and how they were actually
going to operate believe me I will keep
pressing frankly bask in the questions
but like I say I think there is a lot
more work to be done by county on this
when it comes to children centers this
council did respond to the consultation
on children centers raising a number of
points in my view extremely valid points
my understanding is that they have had
an awful lot of responses on the
children's centers issues these I
understand the knees are being
considered and doubtless will be taken
on board by county but at the end of the
day this is a county council decision we
have made our representations one of the
things I will say is I intend to playing
a full role both on the health and
well-being board and on the portfolio
holders meeting to make sure we
understand what is going on and our
interests are protected
I was looking the other team to aspect
mr. chairman the agriculture lapse
aspect for the first time for some years
we are now making a profit on milk
because we are able to export it oh man
China cheese to America against the
rules of the BRICS if you what about it
that way
situation ease though all the
development that we have in nova hampton
the have a scheme where we have
affordable homes we have affordable
homes the people that want a job there
now I don't know exactly how they've
done it but all I'm saying is the old
days you had a farm cottage for the farm
work it will be you can't have a factory
as his next to the factory but there is
a scheme and I think there's a lot of
people from in an area which is much
cheaper than here to try and get here
but jobs and that's something I think we
could look at this last week I had a
found a baby of 8 weeks old in the tent
homeless on the Greenway and I found two
people who were homeless in tents with
cars so there is a homeless problem
they've got jobs but I think if we could
look not a criticism but it's work and
play or whatever you like to say our see
Darrin's looking but I think I think
it's something that we are doing a good
job but I think we could do better thank
you
when I first saw this report
I thought rubbish what rubbish in a good
way we look at 70% of our residents feel
satisfied that Stratford keeps public
land clear of little and refuse arrest
refuse collection Services has a 90%
positive positive right feedback from
residents and our reside thing is
tremendous as well being seventh out of
all of all white collects and the
authorities so the many things that this
council is doing well and I particularly
want to congratulate the refuse and
recycling part of the council that's
certainly improving our district what
there is a is a but the way the council
actually deals with local residents on
page 23 61% of our survey do not agree
but are very much agree that Stratford
district council involve residents when
making decisions and also 58 percent of
residents on page 23 did not all agree
or very much agree that's about the
district council acts on the concerns of
local residents again pretty high
percentage so I think we do need more
cedilha more to involve our local
residents and to involve them in
decision makings wherever possible and
this is particularly relevant and
pertinent to communities that are a long
way from Stratford itself for example
Southam we have some residents who've
come here today and that is particularly
44 mile round trip to make themselves
heard so I think we do need to make sure
all parts of their district to hurt
north south east and west and people
have access to council council offices
and councillors themselves in a way
that's easy
transparent and able to make themselves
heard and that means the law unofficial
quiet thank you
chairman I'm pleased to hear of
councilor crumbs conversion from a
rubbish report to an upbeat report but
let me assure him that Southam is a very
important part of this district has
always been considered so and I hope I
have for one have a track record of
making certain that Southam isn't
disadvantaged we have our
representatives including councillor
Crump around the table and indeed we can
effectively hopefully be inclusive
whether or not his other point about
involving residents in decisions can be
literally turned on its head from the
figures he quotes I don't know I think
there comes a time through survey when
we actually consult people to decide if
we're doing it right and the
satisfaction index that we had this year
largely based on that performance in
refuse and recycling certainly suggested
that we were get it right but not long
after we did the satisfaction survey we
had the peer review group that said you
know good Council we like what we see
but and there are some issues that they
have to resolve now oddly enough in
response to councillor Moore's bricks it
was not one of them I think we're
working on the principal counselor Morse
that we don't necessarily follow the
doom and gloom because we have the
Liberal Democratic Party that unity
thinks it's a complete disaster to leave
Union Europe therefore brings it's got
to be a disaster and we'll start arguing
about uncertainty we are at a delicate
point in negotiations because there's a
lot of brinksmanship going on within the
European Union of people that just say
run
we need money earlier
off we go but effectively we could have
a long debate about that and I don't
propose to so we'll get none of the more
basic things now let's have a look at
issues councilor Floyd chick was right
in that the house price index compared
to earnings is a little bit stronger
than we would like it to be I do worry
that young people can't get on the
housing ladder I was able to many years
ago and I would wish the same thing on
the latest generations however that is a
correct issue to raise but as somebody I
think reports it to him he can
effectively use his position on the
affordable housing working group to
actually do that and I made certain that
he did have a place on that committee so
that he could effectively overcome his
Democratic deficit and contribute to the
council's work and we would welcome that
the health and well-being hubs well I
think we are in a better way in health
and well-being because I've taken steps
recent weeks to a point counselor
Jefferson to actually major on that and
that's not to criticize any of his
colleagues and my colleagues that have
done the job before in a different way
but I do anticipate with counselor
Jefferson around that table there could
well be a more positive impact and then
I better shut up in case I've upset
anybody in the process however what I am
also personally involved in is not
cavorting with ministers but effectively
dealing with other leaders across
Britain across the country in looking at
a stronger role for districts in the
health and well-being agenda and I would
ask you to watch this space we've had a
little bit of turmoil I mean getting
office to support at the LG
to do that work but that is now resolved
and I hope I can confidently predict
that we will have a bigger a better role
the problem was when the government gave
Public Health to local authorities in
2013 would you believe they did two
things they first of all set up a new
bureaucratic department called public
health England that think the government
still run public health then they gave
them the lion's share of the budget and
what was their if they go to County
Council's
County Council's are different to us
County Council's operate over a much
bigger area and we're sometimes in touch
with people to a degree that is our
strength and it is our particular
strength in driving the public health
agenda so I think there are two examples
there where I think we will improve that
in the months to come
as far as this district concerned
councillor Cargill's report about
apprenticeships he's dead right yes
there wasn't elitism that said
everybody's got a year the University
and I guess that the lawful lot of
parents would encourage their children
to attend University I certainly didn't
one did the other one didn't but the
issue is that the one size doesn't
necessarily fit all but we do have a
situation where apprenticeships are
vital getting the our teas and skills
are vital and as well as actually taking
objective relationships within the
district to encourage exactly what
councillor Cargill wants to achieve we
also need to work with our partners
elsewhere in making certain that we
reshape the local authority agenda
though so that counts of the college
agenda the agenda on funding and that's
something that again I and officers are
working hard on right before I run out
of time
I have to effectively talk about
shovel-ready schemes we have a major
deport I stand here I say let's look
forward and the first thing does that
counselor more stands up and says we
didn't have shovel-ready schemes ok
whatever you want to argue about that
the funding for Priory square in Studley
has been cancelled by the LEP it was
cancelled since this report was
published we had the information last
Monday and I was simply told it's gone
we've decided it's gone and effectively
this council is now going to ask
questions about decision-making within
the local enterprise partnership itself
I've had a dialogue with mr. Webb about
this and we're going to set those wheels
in motion because there are issues that
will have to be raised however we won't
let it go I've got a question coming
back later so we'll deal with that one
then and we will make certain that the
effectively Priory Square gets the
promise that we've allocated to it over
a long period of time whether this
councilors involved in its development
or somebody else's but what's happened
in fact is the coop independently of us
decided to do a deal with a developer
and that has put that funding in genic
jeopardy nothing to do with this council
and we're still working quite hard now
it's a pity councillor Rich's he's not
very well today he tells me so he's not
here he's the master of shovel-ready
schemes and he's been the one that's
been detailed since he's been imposed to
actually get some ready I effectively
I'm quite confident that when he returns
to full fitness he'll be able to stand
in front of this council and report some
positive news in that area because we
have had some research done it's been
reported to Council we have got a long
list we have got a relationship with
some parts of the LEP which is positive
and indeed councillor Rich's his role is
positive so
it's a bit like him being good guy and
me being bad guy here why why did you
make that decision I want to know why
and then Peter Rich's will come along
and say but we're perfect we've got all
these schemes in the pipeline smile at
us so but however whichever way it works
it will work and we will deal with that
and we will make certain so consequently
probably I've covered the major points
or poverty statistics I've got a note
here they were queried whether 2013 was
the right figure I'm advised that we
just don't have any more up-to-date
figures and Simon / Phil put the most
up-to-date figures that we had but I
would hope that if the most up-to-date
figures are four years old something
more recent will come and if it confirms
the trend that has been reported in the
report then child poverty is on a
downward trend in Stratford district but
we have to remember we might have a lot
of people that can afford expensive
houses we also have an awful lot of
people that work in industries where the
wage they get is scarcely above the
living wage it's very low it's very
light these people need to be able to
afford housing which is why we are
involved at the moment in planning for
example in looking at the questions of
supply of affordable housing developers
questioning whether our demands are too
great but we are reform reinforcing the
standards that we put into the core
strategy that we adopted last year to
make certain but low paid workers can
afford to live in Stratford district
that is vitally important they might
need it might not solve every problem
and they might still live in difficult
times but we can I hope
make certain that we provide the degree
of support and that's why on the health
and well-being
I think we ought to have an influence
and remind the county council just how
big Stratford district is they're three
three hubs are good enough in Warwick
district we probably need twenty three
in Stratford district because of its
relative size you might smile counselor
fragile II but I think you're agreeing
with me yeah we do have I think I'm not
a county council anymore but one of the
things I found when I was there they do
have difficulty in understanding the
sheer size and logistics of operating in
Stratford district and I would urge all
people that are there to reinforce that
point so I think we have mr. chairman on
the main and not B report we've had a
good debate I'm pleased about that
and we'll take the points that have been
raised forward into the future well
thank you leader of the council for your
detailed response which is sure is very
much appreciated we now move on to
matters for determination by the council
and the first is the audit and standards
committee of the 25th of September where
I call upon councillor Barker as vice
chairman of the audit standards
committee to introduce this item may I
just congratulate councillor Barker on
becoming chairman but you haven't been
formally appointed so it's not a
substantive rank you are still temporary
unpaid temporary unpaid and this is a
test I presume mr. Chiang
can I refer counselors please to page 35
of the agenda where you will find the
minutes of the meeting relevant to the
review of the code of conduct on the
25th of September I would just like to
point out that we were advised by Paul
Roy of hoi an's cough and cough so she
'its
who is here today so if there are any
technical questions that anybody's got
I'm going to appear at him and hopefully
he will answer them and I want to move
and recommend to council the
recommendation on page 37 mr. chairman
do I actually need to read that out or
can I allow everyone to read it
themselves
can I take that as read thank you we
have a question yeah a couple of
comments on it leader and and if we've
been whipped on it so I'm plan to
abstain rather than vote against or
anything but I have three issues with
where the code of conduct has got to so
in an ideal world it would be deferred
but I know probably won't be firstly I
been held up on a code of conduct to a
few times or always dismissed but on one
occasion I remember it went on for a
couple of years this council spent
something like 20,000 pounds
investigating me only for me to
ultimately receive apology because I
never should have turned out I never
should been investigated in the first
place because it wasn't a matter that
should have been dealt with under code
of conduct so what concerns me is what
the threshold is for councillors to
actually be investigated in the first
place it doesn't seem that that
definition is clear enough secondly is
I'm surprised when it comes to who from
outside is asked to investigate
councillors there's not some clarity
about a panel potentially of law firms
or third party lawyers who we would use
nor to say that our monitoring officer
does anything like this but I know
elsewhere that sometimes it feels like
it's a bit of a job for the boys and the
mates of monitoring officers elsewhere
end up getting their mates to do it as a
means of topping up their compensation
and I struggle with that I think early
on we should have a very clear
definition of who our third-party
panelists are who can investigate
councillors so it's clear from the
integrity governance point of view
there's no issues and then finally one
thing that did disturb me here was the
way there is almost in times carve-outs
about offices we've we've had a resident
talk about being misled by officers I
know of some of the planning processes
people are very concerned these days and
it may be sharing the volume of work and
we'll come to later on in this meeting
about that but when an officer purely
has done something wrong it strikes me
that these are these are sort of carving
out almost saying well you still can't
you
have a girl an officer I just think you
know they're not above the law and
sometimes I think this implies that
maybe they are and I was concerned about
that so if maybe castle Barca you could
just know those points I'd be much
obliged thank you thank you councillor
Hillary I noted them chairman can I just
ask for an immediate response from the
monitoring officer to some of the
comments council Vaudrey has made Thank
You chairman
so three three points that were made
firstly about the threshold for the
start of a formal investigation when
someone has complained about the
behavior of a member this is set out in
the complaints procedure document which
is published on the council's website
that document hasn't changed for the
last three or four years so it's not
part of any changes that are being
proposed today and if you've looked at
the document you'll see that there are a
number of criteria that are set out in
the document that I won't rehearse here
which are factors that are taken into
account in deciding whether to start an
investigation or not secondly with
regard to mates I'll be interested to
know whether there be any evidence in
relation to this council I'm certainly
not aware of any such relationship again
in the complaints process it clearly
states how we actually appoint and
commission investigators if that's
necessary we ask them we ask them to be
demonstrate to us that they've got the
qualifications and experience to carry
out the role they also have to produce a
schedule showing how their investigation
will be run and that is normally shared
with the complainant and the subject of
the complaint lastly with regard to
officer complaints I'd respectfully say
that this particular item has nothing to
do with officer complaints but there is
a later question I understand that you
will be addressing thank you
you know counsel Barker did you want to
pick up the point yes I would like to
mmm thank the monitoring officer for
doing the technical stuff there and I
need that the final question that
counsel of audio brought up is a
question which you will find on the pink
paper but investigating complaints the
indicator condo didn't has anything to
deal with that I would say that we had
we had really good discussions we had
roundtable events to discuss the new
count code of conduct and the real nub
of the of it is to make it simpler more
transparent and more importantly to give
examples so people have an idea of where
they stand with regards to particular
issues contained in the code of conduct
and the feedback we've had so far from
people has been very positive from
councils and parish counselors and from
independent persons as well so I would
commend the new code of conduct to you I
hope people had a chance to read it and
I was saying I will move the
recommendation on page 37 Thank You
chairman a very brief point about the
recommendation itself on page 37 to be
all district councillors be required to
attend one of the two training sessions
on Thursday the 15th of March I've no
problem whatsoever chairman of this
council deciding that all councillors
should attend a training session I'm
fully supportive of that my only concern
is what happens if somebody can't make
it on the 15th of March and when we say
required to attend that suggests there
is some penalty for those councillors
who don't attend
could I ask councillor Barker what
penalty she has in mind
a stone slapped to myself because I
can't day the 15th if I'd refer you to
page 36 you'll see that there are two
training sessions on that date and there
is also a further training session on
the 22nd
are you are you moving to amend it I'm
quite happy to suggest that we that we'd
make a comment in here that all
councillors should be required to attend
training session within a period of say
one month are you happy to second that
council Parker I'm perfectly happy to
second that as long as everybody does
the training and complies with the code
of conduct
Thank You Jana I was actually gonna how
would a second did that because I think
certainly for me I'm as full-time
employed as it possibly gets so it's
somewhat tricky and some of my
colleagues are as well and I think we
should be representing we should
represent a cross-section of the entire
society so listen yes oh good
and then a comment as with all of these
reports I'm just going to start being a
pain with these now not specifically in
relation to this one but it's much
easier to understand what's changed if
you give me a chart of changes so
instead of just the revised code of
conducts what I would have appreciate it
was a track changes document in my
business that's all we deal with this
this is what we changed this is the
revised policy rule or paragraph but
that's only a minor issue really thank
you
excuse me mr. chairman we haven't voted
on the recommendation yet we haven't
actually voted on the recommendation it
was just the amendment sorry we've done
the amendment were all happy with the
recommendation
you will have been presented not only
with a copy of the paperwork for this
morning's meeting which was published a
week last Friday but a copy of the
minutes for this morning's meeting which
contains two recommendations to counsel
I'm going to deal with them in order
because chairman they are is separate
items on the council agenda this after
fact that the back isn't too good all
right now ah was my fault okay mayor
pooper sorry I'm speaking counselor
brain always in a technical query so
hopefully everybody can hear me
although having been trained as a young
boy to project my voice on stages I'm
not usually difficult to be heard right
carrying on you have a copy of the
minutes of this morning's cabinet
meeting and it relates to two items
which have been referred for a decision
to council which is why we held at the
meeting this morning otherwise we delay
those until next meeting of full council
which is on the 11th of December so
consequently I'm going to take them one
by one because they're separate items on
your agenda chairman and the first is
the aptly named local development scheme
the local development scheme is a
timetable
it's a timetable of events and over the
years it's been often updated and every
time I'm force
to come here and stand on this platform
and say we need to change it I get
challenged from this side of the room as
to why it has had to be updated however
I'm pleased to inform you that there are
positive reasons for the update we
adopted our core strategy in July last
year and the wreaths the most recent
modifications that went into there from
the planning inspector required us to do
certain things and one of the things it
requires us to do was a site allocations
plan so we've had to do that since the
core strategy was adopted it also
required us to have SPG supplementary
planning guidance for certain
developments and the supplementary
planning guidance was for our two
strategic allocations at gayden the
lights on 8th and at Long Marston gave
light on Heath has been done but I
accept it but long marcin hasn't and the
councillor subsequently decided to
actually do supplementary planning for
what is known as the canal quarter this
is a run down part of Stratford where
we're going to try and relocate some
businesses and redevelop the site on a
mixed-use basis and effectively there
are some quite positive ideas coming
forward in the background I'm not in a
position to present them to you this
afternoon so consequently I'm going to
look at the local development scheme and
if you've got your cabinet papers rather
than is it'll give you a chart a Gant
chart which says the site allocations
plan and the [ __ ] and Traveller plan
sadly will be delayed until June 2019
I regret that delay but we've had
effectively to deal with certain other
things and the long-lasting airfield SPD
will be done by next April but can now
course our SPD by July next year and a
thing called the development
requirements SPD which will store all
these niggly questions that we keep
being asked the planning committees what
are we doing about parking om Ghani
rules that said the officers well
slow as it might be we are making the
rules and they will come forward so
consequently all these things have to be
scheduled we have to schedule them in a
way that resources can cope but I'm
pleased to say that although we are
delaying certain things with this
revised timetable we are executive Li I
am being far more confident that it will
be delivered because the staffing in the
policy section is more or less up to
strength it's not quite there but it's
it's almost there and we've made great
strides in recent weeks to improve our
staffing capacity so basically with all
that long rigmarole I've got a simple
job here this afternoon saying we've
devised this new scheme this new style
this new timetable it's called the local
development scheme we have to report it
to CLG that's the sting in that so if
they weren't poking their nose into what
we were doing we could probably get away
without doing it well why shouldn't have
said that but anyway but the issue is
that it's a mandatory requirement and I
would like councils endorsement of the
timetable there and the minute from this
morning confirms that the timetable in
the plan was recommended to Council by
Cabinet this morning
was yummy final point of the day
Gemma this was debated this morning I
have no problem to the overall plan
however I would bring two members
attention the delays on the Gypsy and
traveler site plan this was originally
intended to be agreed in July 2016
the new date is now july 2019 and we are
three years late German canceled the st.
pointed out this morning that one of
difficulties was that when we put out a
call for sites no sites were forthcoming
and I think we all understand that I
think members need to understand the
vulnerability of many of our rural areas
if applications come forward without a
plan in place we are not in a position
is Lee to oppose many of these so I hope
chairman anything we can do to bring
this plan forward will be done purely so
that we can protect our rules
thank you yeah yes chairman I kind of
accept the criticism except councillor
Moss his starting point was a little bit
exaggerated peak true that dealt with
the examination in public of the core
strategy decided that it wasn't
necessary or mandatory to have a oh no
he didn't he effectively excused us from
dealing with that and effectively he
approved as sound a plan a core strategy
with no GNC plan in it as as you rightly
quoted there are problems because if you
want land to develop for a G&T site the
people who own that land scratch their
heads and think god
we could build a housing estate here
instead of housing gypsies and
travellers and it will be worth a lot
more money and we have had some complex
problems with looking at local authority
land so I won't go into those now which
actually have handicapped us but I agree
with councillor Morse we should do with
this as quickly as possible
but this is the timetable that
the officers have reported is practical
yes I think the spirit is taken and is
everyone now happy with the two
recommendations which would determine
this morning at the cabinet meeting
agreed thank you very much item 9 is a
strategic review group and again for
council site chairman this is the result
of an awful little work that we have
done in recent months and I would like
to compliment colleagues of mine we set
up a strategic review group for cabinet
members and for others and that cabin at
that group has steadfastly met over
several months now and has done an awful
lot of good work which has resulted in
the report we have today now the report
we have today does conclude that phase
of the strategic review group but times
the strategic review group split into
working groups and looked at certain
issues he looked at benchmarking it
looked at the ways we work it looked for
opportunities to raise money and it
looked at policy issues those four
groups were meeting regularly and their
recommendations are summarized in the
report you have before you today
I won't we've all had a chance to read
it so I won't necessarily pick up on
anything particular this afternoon I
will than to identify the depth of work
on top of that what we have done is we
did this early days we were complemented
on it in the course of the work of the
review the we actually decided that we
haven't as a council communicated with
some of our business stakeholders
somebody referred earlier this afternoon
to whether or not we can have residency
involved in work that's right that's
true that's fine had a line I have my
meeting with them from time to time but
equally well we have an awful lot of
businesses in this district that pay us
a lot of money in business rates so much
more that we collect more than we're
allowed to keep and they effectively
were not being consulted they weren't
being consulted in the drive of the
district in the direction it was going
and I referred to this in the state of
the district report a short while ago so
consequently we set up a whole series of
meetings with businesses and found that
they thoroughly enjoyed talking to us
rather than sitting in the room
somewhere at the back of a thing at the
end of a letter or whatever or even an
email and effectively since then we've
held two lunches with different sets of
those stakeholders where we've sat down
to a rather meager lunch on my heart
because the District Council was paying
for it but the issue is that they have
come along they have talked to us about
our work and given us some good advice
on how to facilitate that work how to
handle it and we've also engaged with
people outside the district's day-to-day
work you know the last one for example
we had we we had a lot of information
coming back but how the railway industry
is organizing itself it Stratford
district because we had a representative
there from London Midland and as such we
were able to deal with it but we also
had representatives the birthing
industry from nfu mutual and at the
first meeting we had that County can
we have various other people I can't
remember everybody that came to every
occasion and I haven't written myself
out of crib list so I apologize if you
think I'm deficient in telling you who
turned up they are all being represented
over a period of time and such has been
the perceived success of this we are
going to repeat that so our involvement
with stakeholders and in view of the
decision that's being made by government
to hand over more of the business rates
to local authorities these people are
becoming major funders of the work that
we do for everybody the public the
industry businesses the like and as such
it is vitally important that we maintain
that dialogue however the key issues are
that we've looked at ideas which are
dest down as proposals they're not down
as decisions we will work them up for
example at the present time we refurbish
this building 15 16 years ago and since
then found that we didn't need a door so
a big floor on the ground floor was
first of all leased out to the Royal
Shakespeare Company when they'd finish
with it when they rebuilt their theaters
it went to Washoe County Council and for
some obscure reason and I don't
understand they've decided they don't
need it anymore
and that we've let it out to a private
company it's the same we went in the
house over the road which has been used
as a register office for some time quite
a nice Airy room but there's a new one
being created elsewhere in the town and
the County Council responsible for that
so consequently we only occupy part of
this building we reckon we could occupy
a smaller part of this building and
steps are being taken to see how we can
fit everybody in now there are two key
issues to that one is our officers are
going to have to store
stack up far less paper well I set no
example if you look at my office there
are heaps of paper everywhere but what
this requires and I'm sorry mr. platts
this is the second time you've heard me
say this today but we're going to be
very reliant on you to actually devise a
new system of IT communications in order
to manage with far less paperwork you
know the strengths of our IT system we
know areas where it needs and if we
involve a staff in home working they're
gonna have to be available not oh you
can email them we're gonna have to ring
them up as well and make them available
that though could and would and should
release office space which we can sublet
like we have on the floor by the
entrance so there's one example one very
important example and acceptable there
is a time limit but so therefore I
probably use my time up to introduce
this item I could talk about other
things and no doubt those of you that
have read report may have other things
that I can refer to in in in the summing
up but the state of the district I'm
pleased to report has got to the stage
where we finalized areas of study we've
looked at what's important both for
saving money to balance the books
because if we don't balance the books
all these reserves that councilor moss
keeps referring to are going to get
spent they're going to get spent because
our books don't balance and he knows
that he might tease us about it but he's
well aware of that
so consequently this is the way we've
got to work forward to somehow we've
revised I won't say revolutionize I once
got criticized by a colleague of mine
for saying I'm not excited enough about
the future here well I'm an engineer by
profession and I get my ducks in line
before I make it is
so consequently I'm afraid that's the
way I work but it's I hope it serve this
council well in recent years and will
continue to do so but I think we have a
very positive report and a very good way
forward and of course we should come
back to the points in this report in the
months to come as we gradually implement
more and more other decisions and
certainly you know we'll have to we'll
have to bring matters to full council
sometimes because there's no other way
of deciding thank you German Thank You
councillor st. the minutes have been
produced and I just draw members
attention to the fact there compared
with the recommendations there are
slight amendments nothing critical but
do we have any particular questions on
the report as submitted yes councillor
kettle and just relating to the comments
I made at the start of the meeting in
the reports to cabinet it listed the
four key priorities navigation stubbly
wells borne priori and then it had a
subsequent paragraph relating to work we
might or might not do with China I
notice that we've listed the four items
here on page three recommendation the
pages are numbered could you just
clarify of the grip of the leader just
clarify where we are on what happened to
paragraph two point six
sadly I didn't want to bore the pants
off everybody by referring to everything
and I run out of time but paragraph 2.6
yes does refer to the work that you've
been involved in and I've been involved
in and I've been very pleased to lead in
dealing with our friends in China and
the cultural exchanges the issue is that
we don't have any specific
recommendations to make that other than
the ones that you emphasized earlier
yourself and that is keep up the good
work have a dialogue with them if they
decide again for the third year running
to come to the birthday celebrations
next year then we will entertain them ok
if they invite us us seems likely to go
out there in September next year then we
will go and enjoy their company but at
the same time what we're doing is we're
making certain that the profile of
Stratford in China is increased so that
people will come there they will have to
boost their own thing and at 161 pound
for a visa I reckon they've got a bit of
a handicap there to their tourist
economy but the the issue is that that
that is that the way forward we will
actually sort of see it through our work
we will advise and contribute to their
work on rebuilding that little bit of
Stratford not the whole of the town in
in foucha and as a consequence it's very
much on our agenda but we don't have any
specific proposals at the present time
other than to maintain a very positive
and healthy dialogue with them no other
questions so councillor for tech
just down on page 21 on the council's
activities for strategic projects on the
upper Aven navigation kind of urge the
council going forward with this
particular issue to tread tread water
very carefully it's an amazing piece of
River if any councillors have ever been
on this part of the river the ecology
and the area of outstanding beauty is
quite an amazing it made it
I've been on rivers all over the country
and this particular stretch is probably
one of the most beautiful in England so
I would hope counselors would treat this
particular issue with great caution
Thank You chairman do I detect that
councillor for Chang has had a chance to
navigate the upper Aven before anybody
else has you know if he's been on all
these bits of river however on the
serious side yeah it was approved it's
in our list it's very early days as far
as any involvement is concerned there
have been some fears expressed and I
would like to allay those fears so at
the present time we have some projects
we need to get them up and ready I doubt
whether this one will be particularly
quickly and we will concentrate on focus
on others but regrettably my colleague
Peter Richards is not with us today I
don't know whether he's climbing out of
his sickbed yet or not but unfortunately
it would have been benefited for his
input to the meeting but no doubt that
will evolve in the fullness of time but
I understand the caution that we need
Thank You leader and can I assume that
all members are happy with the
recommendations in the minutes produced
of the cabinet meeting from this morning
all in agreement
fine thank you very much there's now
turn to item 10 which is committee
reports and the first one all
standard committee counselor Barker yeah
no I'm not gonna do it Teresa may know
it's not gonna last but too much talking
you've already seen the major part of
the 25th of September committee report
from audit and standards and I would
commend it to you I'm just turning to
the right page that's what we will
accept the spirit of the question we are
happy with what was produced oh it's all
members happy yes the minutes of the
employment of the employments committee
on the 11th of July have been published
and happy to take any questions I
present them to Council all happy all
agree fine overview and scrutiny
committee of the 28th of June 12th of
July 26th of July
blimey in the 6th of September
councillor Jefferson we haven't got the
promotions up to date yes thank you
councillor house I'm pleased to advise
members that the the agenda reports for
the 28th of June the 12th of July the
26th of July and the 6th of September
are available on the website for your
perusal
with regard to any questions since I've
only just taken over this put this
committee I hope there won't be any but
what I would like to finish by saying is
that I will try and continue the good
work that was set up by councillor Tony
Jefferson over the last two years thank
you Tony yep thank you
regulatory committee council in law
successfully and the cabinet's 17th of
July 31st of July knee length of
September few meetings ever all those
meetings had
minutes publish the statuses of decision
but I'm happy to take further questions
now I present them to Council as with
the others no questions you're all happy
with what has been minuted fine thing
all I basically have to do is find out
do you have a supplementary to make yeah
now I know that counselor Bromwich has
given apology so the first two will go
by whatever one wishes counselor for
tech do you have a supplementary to
question three on the agenda kind of a
question as well it's just really saying
HMOs do require special status as women
can be a bit more likely to be using
them with a lack of regulation on
inspection and inadequate informations
and doesn't give this council really the
correct information to require to invest
in its housing department to see how big
this problem actually is really we need
to look at this to create extra capacity
in the housing department to gauge the
scale of this problem the state of the
district already shows large low earning
economy in Stratford this leads to I
believe an underworld black market
economy of low cost low quality
unregulated housing of Haiti roses it's
an issue I feel it just can't be pushed
into the carpet who Richards is not here
but councillor Dave riches has
volunteered to reply hi Thank You chair
yeah I volunteered to stand in poppy as
usual councillor for checks intentions
are always honorable especially with
regards to dangerous housing situations
and I'm sure Pete has got this on his
radar the reassurance I can give you
from today is I'll make sure that I
speak to him and see what can be done I
don't have to sound like it's being
brushed into the carpet it's not and I'm
sure that he's wouldn't brush it under
the carpet is really important so I can
give you the confidence that I'll make
sure he's got
he's right now he's working on it Thank
You councillor forecheck question 4 is
from you you're quite happy good no
supplementary excellent council of
fragile e do you have a supplementary
question Thank You chair the council
intends to further consider and take
advice on the issue of planning blight
please can you let me know when this
advice might be made available to
councillors and the public because
blight will be happening as some of the
more major infrastructure issues go
forward so is there any information in
that area Thank You mr. chairman I don't
have any information on timing of advice
because of the response points out it is
very much to do with Carla homes and
planning applications on that road and
they are being dealt with as a unique
individual entity separate from the
housing development but nonetheless an
integral part of our traffic
infrastructure I would like to give you
an assurance so that I see no reason why
we can't actually share any information
we get with the local ward members but
that will be when it would become
available I need to be guided by mr.
Grafton his team as to the likelihood of
the timing of that and I expect he'll be
as uncertain as I can be this afternoon
the for the firaon sir what information
will the accounts will be providing on
monitoring this piece of new legislation
so that we can actually make sure
there'll be no adverse effects from it
Richards yes um Thank You chair I'm not
was up today on this is his counselor
Richards is so I would probably suggest
that you took you out with him outside
of the meeting sorry question seven
counsel Morse do you have a
supplementary nothing on seven but I see
I'm eight as well Jeff thank you it's to
the leader and I noticed that now course
strategy estimated houses needed per
year is 724 the government's recent
indicative of assessment housing need in
this district was 588 considerably less
than our core strategy figure what what
reason does cancer st. give for the
government's assessment of housing meet
being so much lower than our core
strategy assessment need chairman for
once I've been slightly wrong foot hit
by councillor Moss because they have
long promised a standard method of
calculating your OAM your objectively
assessed housing need and this is it
three weeks ago in a consultation paper
so to a degree we can't really even do
anything with the figures except reply
to the consultation if they bring in
secondary legislation because I think it
would have to be that to actually
implement this then we would have
specific questions to for you to ask and
for me to respond to but I think in the
meantime all I can say is this is a
consultation we are carrying on as
normal
nine counsel Roth
oh yes the dhurbey supplementary Thank
You chef this question came about really
because I met a couple a few weeks ago
an elderly couple whose wife wife had
just been diagnosed with dementia I had
no idea that they could have a discount
there the social capital itself will be
booked online and I don't think many of
us in this really whatever turn our
council tax papers I think looking back
the CalSTRS forms so I do think we need
to advertise it a little bit more I'm
gonna make a couple of suggestions one
is that perhaps we were to put something
in the next review magazine that we send
out to the rest of this in Stratford and
I don't think it's beyond us to actually
try and get something into what our
surgeries because it's after the doctors
that probably are ultimately putting
forward the diagnosis and if our doctor
surgeries you then I'm sure that would
help so if that could be undertaken by
you I'd be very grateful thank you yeah
I think that's a good idea
so yeah let's do that as far as the
doctor surgeries are concerned I don't
see any reason why we shouldn't be
printing out an information leaflet and
sending it out that's not gonna cause us
to go bankrupt I wouldn't have thought I
think people do turn over their bill I
think if you want to find out okay but
yeah I'm more than happy to try and make
sure that people who are aware I'm gonna
be concerned that people were out there
didn't know and when making their claim
I do chair so when I talk to the numbers
of it comes to ballpark two and a half
million pounds just kidding awful lot of
money on a core strategy that I think we
all hoped and expected and I certainly
voted for it but it was going to sort of
solve all those planning issues that we
were going to end up being very clear in
defining where House we're going to
build but if we think about the large
developments you've had some of my
residents today
you know with issues about Bishop turn
when I was on the steering
forgave my horn I know cancer Kessel and
other members raised a number of issues
residents in and around Long master of
doing it as well now and when I think
about local service villages we know
that councillor bonds are Welford you
know that there's this or in Biddeford
as well this disparity between is it a
minimum or maximum number on there so I
think there's been loads of issues in
terms of the actual implementation and
execution of planning through the core
strategy so if there's like my very
simple question is given we've already
spent two and a half million that
doesn't mean we should spend less do we
need to spend more and planning officers
to ensure that a number of those issues
that we've had perhaps can be alleviated
because there is the time and effort and
inclination to be on top of it
well the now residents like mine who
often feel they're misled and that may
be on purpose but a major speakers
officers haven't got time to really be
on top of some of these issues I think
chairman councilor Vaudrey raises a
valid point but he's saying because we
spent a lot of money have we spent
enough should we spend more and I'm not
so sure that my instinctive position
necessarily would support that I think
the issue with GL age and bishops in to
a lesser degree was they were a little
bit caught on the cusp of adoption of
the core strategy and a lot of the
issues went through before the core
strategy was in place and were guided by
some of the problems that we encountered
and appeals prior to their determination
the question of Appeals since we had the
core strategy adopted is that we want
considerably more than we had been
almost doubled in fact and therefore
we've got to a stage where the core
strategy has been useful now there are
teething troubles in issue
and I have to say that Biddeford is not
a local service with each I'm sure you
realize that a councillor Audrey but the
other place well further is and I know I
have a couple of them in my ward so I'm
well aware of the issues regarding
housing numbers and indeed the debates
that we've had in the background to
trying to deal with that and to degree I
think in the main that planning policy
is being far more effectively
administered the issues at Southam that
raise an area of restraint again before
the core strategy was adopted I think no
I might be wrong but however the issue
was that we certainly have had some
indeterminant methods so I don't want to
confuse that problem when we were
without a five-year land supply we were
without a proper planning policy and
certain things and decisions were going
wrong I don't want that to confuse the
issue with today where we have got a
five year land supply that's been
confirmed we have a sound core policy
and we have a number of decisions not
all of them are very the public don't
always feel happy with all of them but
considerably more are a lot sounder I
must also draw your attention councillor
Vaudrey to the fact that in 2012 we
virtually had to rip up everything we've
been doing and start again because a
certain champ called Eric Pickles says
we don't want you to make your core
strategies compatible with regional
spatial strategies because I'm going to
abolish them we want you to make your
core strategies compatible with the
national planning pay policy framework
which he or his assistant Greg Clark
introduced in 2012 so the key issue is
that we did spend a lot of money because
that change
want us to do a lot more research and we
had a full report from Liam Nevin who
was the officer in charge of the core
strategy at the time so consequently we
I think we are in a better place I'm not
inclined to increase the the staffing
I'm inclined to make certain that our
teams are fully staffed because I think
that's a key element we've had cases
where we haven't had a full time staff
in places we had a long period when we
have a lot of temporary staff in places
but we've kind of put all those behind
us so that's my view of the situation
that we are in a better place I hope
that in a few months time you will be
able to respect that and notice that in
the decisions that we're making there I
do so I think councillor Barca as chair
desmet of all different standards for
her response I wanna tell the story if I
may a couple of months ago I filed a
complaint against a planning enforcement
officer and is this a related to your
specific question absolutely absolutely
sure it's absolutely related it leaves
switch entirely but I just get
clarification on that please well the
clarifications for me that's pretty the
question chair I have to raise a
question here my point is going to
directly comment on the senior officers
of this Association I cannot accept a
monetary officer trying to stop me
making a comment that directly impacts
him so you've got to respect that
chairman I've told you this is related
to this question you've seen from what
you have just said you appear to be
coming on to a subject which may not be
entirely related to your original
question until you - it isn't so unless
it is related in all ways I won't accept
your supplementary well chair I'm
telling you it is related in all ways
well I cannot determine that from
what you have said what what about just
started yeah with respect yeah you're
taking advice from a monitoring officer
who I have okay what I will tell you
chair is I have had to report various
senior officers to the police because
there was no responsibilities District
Council you are and I've revealed into
the water because unless you start doing
my question is tourists a share of the
audio MIDI to ensure the Lisa Mays
inflow is Lea properly administered in
this council members research thank you
outrageous chair are you enjoying that
who do you want the three of us to go
through the difficulty of this crisis
this is a personal thing to do
chair
thank you for halal Madras this question
will councillor Barca commit to the
audit and Standards Committee carrying
out an investigation into the way senior
officers handle complaints against them
obviously under the purview of the audit
and Standards Committee I will do what
is necessary I'd say I just want to
repeat one sentence from the report back
at the answer the question when a
service failure is identified the aim is
to take action quickly to rectify the
situation and I'm satisfied that the
process is robust and transparent at
home but obviously if there is any
individual with any wrongdoing buying an
individual that comes to us I will
investigate thoroughly
I've no supplementary from the first
question but I have got a supplemented
for my second question because the way I
read the answers to my question about
housing and I read the answers to care
accounts the Kojak as well I'm left with
the seemly and I could be wrong
but it is a feeling I've got that there
was a breakdown in the housing
department for about three months and
I'm not and there is an explanation as
to how it occurred so I do want
reassurance in some way that this won't
happen again because one of the most
harrowing experiences that I've had as a
councillor is somebody coming to see me
at the village hall a man in his early
thirties poking a small child and
begging for help to get onto the waiting
list I just don't want that experience
again and I'm sure none of the other
councils would want to witness it either
in the absence of pencil Richard we have
Richards councillor Richards who will
reply Thank You chair and I can
sympathize with that situation as well
it's horrific and I've been through
something similar and it would seem on
the outset that something went wrong
during the recess I've got about a text
message off councillor Richards he's in
his flu bed or whatever it is to say
that he will diligently reply to all of
the questions himself as soon as he's
back in the apologies for his absence
yeah we'll make sure that gets followed
up and we should all be watching that
because it is really important it's not
just numbers it's people
the right do you have a supplementary to
your other yes I have you can imagine
the disappointment of this particular
loss of money not just to me but my
understanding is to the offices and to
our leader and everybody really um so
what I'm going to ask is what the
chairman of our young scrutiny please
arrange for the events leading up to the
loss of this grant from the let be a
subject of a scrutiny report with a view
to gaining full understanding of why the
grant was withdraw and divert let and
reporting any lessons that we can learn
from the future because none of us I'm
absolutely sure want to be in this
situation again I was going to add I
feel we've been unfairly treated but I
won't
the leader will respond chairman the
original question was to the leader and
I have taken advice and you can't
suddenly convert it into a question to
the chairman of the OSC I have discussed
it with the chairman of the OSC and
indeed I think there are a number of
initiatives and work strands that we are
undertaking which may well obviate the
need for it to go to the OSC I can't
speak for him as you will know I leave
the OSC to sort out their own work
program but under the rules of
councillors the supplementary question
has to come to the leader and I can't
speak for him however I'd like to assure
you that we are doing as I suggested
earlier in an earlier debate that we are
looking at finding out how and why we
got into this situation
and indeed what remedies that we can
create from it and that includes having
a dialogue with the LEP about
wrong governance because we think that
there are voids in there
okay chairman thank you
it's a defeat for no more than three
minutes Frank gosh
counselor fracturing so it's just a very
quick question I've all stood many times
before I'm still aware that the lights
on the tramway bridge and not performing
as they should be and I just wondered
where we might be with that mr. chairman
I've suggested to cancel the fresh lead
before that I don't carry this
information around in my head and I do
have portfolio holders that could better
answer the question and but if there are
problems with the lights all I can
suggest is that I get mr. perks to have
a look at this and he's putting his
thumb up so we'll get you an answer
offline no doubt you very happy
I'm sorry counselor Vaudrey I have two
questions leader firstly can ask about
the transport strategy I was in mind of
the other day it was February that we
had the so-called 4th traffic summit
we're now in October if I remember the
details of the consultation I sort of
got a early glimpse back in April so I
just wanted to ask do we have a deadline
where that consultation work is going to
be published and when we it is published
what plan is in place then actually
begin to implement the various
recommendations because my recollection
was apart from the relief roads most of
it was fairly well received Thank You
chairman
we need your successor from his sickbed
to fully answer this question but he has
communicated with councillor Rich's so
he must be alive again
but the situation is they had an immense
number of responses to this and as is
happening again with the children's
center consultation the County Council
are effectively extending their
deliberation times to fully take all the
issues I know councillor riches has
expressed his concern to the county
council about that because he and I have
discussed this
it's his job to make certain that we get
this out as quickly as possible but
sadly the circumstances are that it is
in the hands of the County Council and
we continue to put pressure on them in
order to publish it so that we can get
on with some of the issues that arise
from it thank you with two questions
first one being our welcome the fact
that this council's successfully
welcomed two Syrian families into our
community is to lead in our anxious that
we need to welcome the other ten Syrian
families as quickly as possible
considering the fact that this process
is not progressing speed we expected I
do hope that this council can take its
promises very seriously and we've
progressed its commitments as urgently
as possible and second question is the
Equality Human Rights Commission have
expressed concern about hate attacks
it's brexit they've urged political
leaders to turn them their language that
polarized the country legitimized hate
the Conservative MP Damian Green said
political debate was too abusive the
Commission pointed to the killing of our
coders Josh wits along with the attacks
on our streets of which it described as
a stain on our society the concerns were
expressed after the violent act of
terrorism in the name of the violent
white supremacist
the words used by Thomas Maher at his
trial was death to the traitors freedom
for Britain following the killing of the
Labour MP Joe cause a Conservative
councillor made comments on Twitter and
she said I quote utter traitors
following British MEP voting with the
European Parliament against moving
negotiations forward because of the lack
of movement on issues such as EU and UK
citizens rights along with other issues
instead of making an argument on the
issue
brat set the consonants that use
language that makes dissenters of her
personal views enemies of the state or
to traitors
there's counselor jars of refused to
apologize and added further insults in
the herald will counsel st. now show
some moral leadership and remove the
width of councillor Giles Thank You
chairman these are highly charged issues
and I deprecated the use of difficult
language shall we say in any issues and
I'm certainly am no party and no
sympathizer of anybody that discharges
their emotions into what is called hate
crime I'm not going to discuss and
debate here any personal issues that I
might have to deal with councillor Giles
over the articles that appeared in there
she's not here today because she's at
work as a barrister and instructed to
being caught by a judge which means that
I get no rank over calling her here so
she's not here to answer for herself but
I could just assure you that I I think
we have got to moderate our language
comments on Twitter our personal
comments though are not necessarily
questions of the political issues before
us today therefore it's a little bit
difficult for me to handle that right as
far as your first question is concerned
the Syrian refugees you're implying that
we've only had two and there's another
ten to come is that right caster riches
could I ask chairman for that councillor
riches asus is in his portfolio area and
he's better able to give a response than
I am no objections from
subbing for everyone today Thank You
chair so there's been two successes
since I had that in my portfolio council
of Audrey and their Council of Richards
the problem is Jason that it's steered
heavily by the Home Office and the
United Nations and they're extremely
cautious about how quickly they bring
people into the country and integrate
them into the communities I'm sure
you're really well aware of this because
your work so while it's really really
encouraging that you are here and I and
I appreciate the urgency and if we could
resolve it I would be up for bringing
another 50 families in immediately but
we've just not in control of that we can
only facilitate what the Home Office and
the United Nations are steering sadly so
that that's the position is it stands as
I understand it at the moment there's
nothing that can be done to speed that
process up yeah I just might be able to
answer cancel Porter's question if
that's okay
Dave web and I were to meeting last
Wednesday morning when Stephen Rumble
said that the responses the to the
consultation for the distracted
transport strategy will be published end
of the year possibly the beginning of
next year I think that was right wasn't
it no I won't ask Thank You chair for
coming back to me
Irish need not apply the world has
changed quite a bit since then thank
goodness
it's Laban's and forecheck sorry about
this funny thing people get to propose
and secondly notice of motion manga me
chairman just let me show you going to
cabinet I just thought I would tell the
members that we would like get 320
meters of extra royal from Ron Martin
some of you have been on the track which
is you just need to propose this council
I'm just explaining that we have a big
new company which has got its first
train off the production line this week
employing a lot of people in the village
in the area at Ron Martin
and this shuttle will be used and Carla
homes are supporting it but I think it's
an important factor and there we have it
seconded the next one is air quality
annual status report again once the
motion has been proposed and seconded it
will be referred to the cabinet for
consideration and report without debate
I'd like to propose the motion chair
thank you thank you very much as you can
see it will be folded on four